[Musik]
ja ja Herr Maier ich habe sie verstanden
ich habe auch schon alles notiert ja
jetzt passen sie mir momentan richtig
Lärmbelästigung aus der Nachbarwohnung
durch laute Heavy Metal Musik
ja genau
ist dauernd belegt die probierst du die
ganze Zeit dass ich zur geburtstag
[Musik]
an Moment der zermond
jetzt machen wir so ich schicke die
Streife die im Heavy Metal Trottel hin
und dann so vor zum Erna das war dann ja
das war übermorgen 16:30 Uhr
ja machen wir den Termin jetzt fix Ja
oder Nein
seine Finger bist du die Ellenbogen
hinten
jetzt Moment
warum ist Berner von mir so leise
[Musik]
geschlagen
Belästigung und dann so gerne wäre der
Körperverletzung okay danke
und bleibt es bei 16:30 Uhr aber das hat
doch die Schläger schon wieder weg
manche Sachen von selbst erledigen gell
[Applaus]